Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P We've been playing a lot of nice
positive voicemails lately. Here's just an old
fashioned person who doesn't like the show.
Speaker 2: Okay shows disgusting. And
I see. I see why David Pakman has such
a big mouth. That's how I got his last
name. Pacman. Right. Have a good day.
Speaker 1: Is that a Pac-Man video game joke
or something like that? Uh, I don't know. Not
exactly electrifying us in terms of the delivery,
but I'm all right, I guess. I appreciate the voice
mail and a bonus show today. It's going to
be fantastic. Producer Pat will join me.
Don Lemon says he was fired by CNN. Don Lemon
says CNN didn't even try to communicate with
him directly. They told him through his agent.
CNN says we actually did try to meet with them.
What's going on? And how does this relate to
the Tucker Carlson firing and what else is
going to happen? Secondly, the Vegas to California
bullet train, which we've talked about before very
strongly, now has bipartisan support. Will it
happen? Will people say it's a waste of money?
Well, of course they will. And lastly, the Supreme
Court is going to decide, can public officials
block people who criticize them on social
media, or is it in some sense a violation of
the First Amendment? It's an interesting case
with far reaching implications. All of those
stories and more will be on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: David Pakman does not have a soul.
He doesn't have a soul.
Speaker 1: Okay. But it will
be on the bonus show that I can tell you. You
can sign up at join Pacman dot com. You can use
the coupon code indicted for a discount and
you can use the coupon code indicated for an
even larger discount. We have a fantastic week
of shows for you today. Remember? Subscribe free
at youtube.com slash The David Pakman Show. I
will see you on the bonus show for tomorrow.